no electricity no food no water no fuel
for Gaza says Israeli defense minister
yuav
galand home to nearly 2 and a half
million people the Gaza trip has been
under an air Land and Sea blockade
imposed by Israel since
2007 but now it has even come out of the
basics the Israeli Army is bombarding
The besieged Enclave after hamas's
unprecedented attack on
Israel Israel hit more than 1,000
Targets in Gaza including air strikes
that leveled much of the town of banon
in the enclave's northeast
corner Israel formerly declared war on
Gaza on Sunday and is promising more
destruction Israeli air strikes also
targeted jabalia the largest of the Gaza
strip's eight refugee camps the camp is
only 1.4 square kilometers in size but
it is home to nearly 120,000
[Music]
Palestinians we're here in the heart of
jabalia as you can see the destruction
in the camp we here in the trends
roundabout as you can see dozens have
been murdered this is what's happening
in Gazza
destruction is everywhere in Gaza once
bustling with worshippers this mosque is
now barely recognizable from
Air civilians are mainly the ones who
are paying the price hundreds have
already been killed and thousands
injured those who survived now have
nowhere to
go I live in the house away from my
family I ran away from home at 1:00 in
the morning along with my child and my
wife we escaped from being targeted and
came to another targeted place we were
surprised by everything as Fire and
Flames were thrown at us there is no
safe place in the Gaza
Strip Gaza one of the most densely
populated areas in the world has one of
the poorest infrastructures due to the
Israeli blockade what is left of
residential areas Towers hospitals and
the whole infrastructure is being
destroyed now Gaza has seen several Wars
but Palestinians say Israeli attacks on
the city are now turning into a
collective
punishment R SAR Al jazer